the local grocery store opens at nine
its parking lot has six rows each row
can fit seven cars each car has four
wheels how many cars can the parking lot
fit and i encourage you to pause the
video and think about this yourself try
to figure it out on your own so let's
reread this the local grocery store
opens up at nine well that doesn't
really matter if we're thinking about
how many cars can the parking lot fit so
we only have to care about that we also
don't have to care about how many wheels
each car has they're not asking us how
many wheels can fit in the parking lot
so we can ignore that what we really
care about is how many rows we have and
how many cars can fit in each row so
what we have is we have six rows
so we have six rows and each row can fit
seven cars so we're gonna have six
groups
six groups of seven or another way of
thinking about we're gonna have six
times seven
cars can fit in the parking lot well
what's this going to be equal to
well this is literally six sevens added
up so this is the same thing as one
two
three
four
five
six that last seven looks strange
six and we're going to add these up
so we're going to add these up
so 7
plus 7 is 14 21
28 35
42 so 6 times 7 is equal to
is equal to 42 so 42 cars can fit in the
parking lot don't believe me
i made a little diagram here we have six
rows so this is the first row second
third
fourth
fifth six
each row can fit seven cars you see it
here one let me make that a little
brighter
one
two
three
four five six seven so how many cars are
there well you have seven
42 total cars seven
or six
six rows of seven